I was telling Shane Gillis about
um this uh comedian Sophie bottle that I
worked with I've known it for years
great school shooting joke she just said
like it's just not worth it to be a
bully anymore
yeah yeah the best one I heard was uh
with all the guns like it's just it
doesn't Adrian Appalachia has one on her
special on her uh the album baby
skeletons it was like when Parkland
happened and it was happening on Ash
Wednesday and she goes it was even worse
because like all those kids had Targets
on their heads
don't you tell that the night after it
happened and everyone was like
right and then this eruption of laughter
went off and I'm like you gotta take
some chances
personally don't like offending people I
don't want to offend people I want
people who are cool to be like oh right
but like you got to get on that line
which means some dorks are gonna be over
the line dude I'll tell you this this uh
gnarly joke like Gino bisconte
[Applause]
so you know what's [ __ ] gnarly like I
was getting ready to do the Charlie
Sheen roast
um oh yeah I forgot how you're on that
yeah Mike Tyson punch you yeah I ran
into Mike Tyson's fist
sergina bisconti tells me that he sends
me this joke he's like dude look at the
Deus and say who are these people the
last time this many nobodies got roasted
at least great white was playing nice
you don't know there was a [ __ ] fired
a great white concert a bunch of people
died but a lot of those people were
losers
there's more to the story
well here's here's what happened yeah
like I mean I I heard that I I got the
roast you're supposed to be of everyone
signing up for it understood by all the
people in Rhode Island where the fire
happened didn't sign up for it you know
and the arsonist did
Mike but I mean yeah okay so so I tell
Jeffy Ross I'm like I'm like man did I
tell him the joke and and Jeffrey goes I
guarantee you he loved it he says oh my
God you have to use that joke on the
roast oh my God you have to I'm like
dude I would never say anything this is
offensive and he's like oh my God you
have to so we go around like the LA
clubs like practicing like uh our our
roast sets yeah and every I'm like I'm
like whatever I'm at the The Comedy
Store like I'll just throw it out there
and it was like the biggest laugh out of
the whole deal and I started to think
myself oh my God like that joke is kind
of killing like maybe like uh yeah maybe
I'll use it so on at the you know they
taped the roast like a couple days
before or where do they tape it and then
it takes them like a week or so to put
it out yeah you know all the bombs yeah
so uh I'm sorry I said it at the taping
you know I said the the great white joke
and um
the next morning after the taping like
my whole Facebook feed like it's just
people like I put you know it goes
burning hell yeah like hey and I'm like
dude I'm like why do they get it I'm
like I'm like did the roach didn't even
come out yet and what it was
was that there was a writer from
Entertainment Weekly who was present at
the taping sure he was not cool and and
he he uh he wrote up a thing about that
he was at the taping right and he just
wrote up like some examples of jokes
that he included in like a Blog oh he
didn't even [ __ ] on it
he just included it as a list of jokes
that just examples of what was said at
the roast and like somebody in Rhode
Island uh saw the this blog and like
what like was offended and then posed it
was like this viral thing and like
everybody in Rhode Island was so mad at
me and upset like and I'd never been in
that kind of situation because I'm just
not someone who seeks to like be
offensive and hurt people's feelings
like it it affected me so badly I got on
with with Jeffrey Ross with Comedy
Central I'm like I'm on my knees begging
me begging you please please cut that
joke out please cut that
and uh like I issued an apology like the
whole deal and I swear I was it's just
like I get you know I want to defend
people but it's not for them whoever
showed it to them was an [ __ ] you
know it's not for those people why would
you show somebody it's like taking
Minecraft to a [ __ ] Jewish school I'd
be like do you see this you're like
don't show them that right you're not
supposed to see it right well
I don't know I I wanna I wanna see the
problem is it's everything's worldwide
now so if you go to a comedy club
everyone there is like we're in this
dark hole we want to hear these really
dark evil things and that boy signed up
for it's a contract right and then you
show you tell somebody where you get on
their phone and then yeah it's not for
them yeah it's like why would you why
would you bother them right some some uh
or like you know you talk [ __ ] with your
friend about somebody about another
friend and then somebody will go tell
that friend and you're like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you right that's
behind the scenes trash talk yeah that
guy's not supposed to know about that
and it's like why'd you say that I'm
like no no why did I tell you he's like
you know like when you talk [ __ ] about
your friend to Bird
yeah I didn't say that but it was behind
your back dude it's all good
dude you should have said how many times
Bert said I love you during that but I
guess oh yeah that was the first time
doing Molly just rubbing your leg he was
loving a nice cat sat down on the couch
next to him and he was like he's just
staring at this cat just before he
realized it no after he realized after
he realized it and um and then after he
got comedian of the year or something so
maybe you're responsible for that I'm
for sure responsible for it I left his
game I helped him see clearly right and
he said his cat's looking at him he's
dude my cat sees me and I was like yeah
I know he goes you don't know my cat
sees me
I'm like yeah you're feeling it bro if
you guys never heard that he never heard
it I gave him a cash 22. I gave him the
best podcast of 2019. and he on the
podcast he was like I am pissed but also
I get that you know I love good content
so you gave me an amazing pocket Joey
Diaz came over telling the story
watching the sunset behind him we're
both like it was awesome the question is
if you put that podcast behind a paywall
would it do better than who makes 74
million dollars for sure yeah it would
do better than my special orange if
you're Drew available now for free uh
would do it it would do better than
anything I say Bert release the pot it's
been long enough yeah yeah I have Aries
shaffir Jew it's just called juice yeah
it's a theme hour I've never really done
one like that like that hard before I
was Orthodox Jewish I was [ __ ] wow
you were studying scripts I was reading
that about you you went to college and
you studied the Jewish scripture I went
to Seminary I was going to be a rabbi
hard turn when uh did you back out of
that what did you make that turn it's
41st trip 21 years old yeah I got I got
a [ __ ] BJ and it was like uh is this
allowed they were like hard no
I'm out keep it warm for me
it's called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude